éducation réussir sans le bac c'est
possible l'école de la deuxième chance
qui permet aux anciens recalés de
reprendre des études supérieures a le
vent en poupe
plusieurs milliers de personnes en
bénéficient chaque année le bilan du
dispositif était présentée aujourd'hui
thomas rambo grégory vasseur ils n'ont
plus l'âge de passer le bac
d'ailleurs aucun d'entre eux ne l'a
pourtant aujourd'hui il s'inflige trois
heures d'épreuve de philosophie niveau
terminale avec un but en tête décrocher
le diplôme d'accès aux études
universitaires qui offrent le même droit
que le bac
j'accueille énormément d'étrangers je
pensais que ça pourrait apporter un
petit plus d'avoir une main propre
uniquement en anglais parce que je
reçois énormément de regrets
j'écoutais revenir à l'école pour parce
que j'avais pas de bagages
la plupart ont un ca paix ou un bep mais
surtout l'ambition d'évoluer ici on en
propose donc le diplôme de la deuxième
chance c'est plutôt un bac bis c'est à
dire que c'est une autre façon de faire
qu'on a une approche qui est fondée sur
l'individualisation des parcours donc
les stagiaires choisissent leur rythme
de progression et c'est ça qui fait la
vraie différence par rapport au bac
cette année plus de 13 mille étudiants
dont un tiers ont décroché le diplôme en
dix ans le nombre de candidats a doublé
autant dire que la formule fonctionne à
condition d'être très à certains
sacrifices
c'est un challenge ô combien difficile
puisque l' accompagnement familial
les amis sont doivent doivent
accompagner je dire cette formation
c'est pas toujours facile il ya des
week-ends on passe à travailler 37 % de
ceux qui obtiennent le diplôme
poursuivre des études universitaires
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a fait jerry
duval il y a 20 ans il était électricien
et aujourd'hui il est maire à plein
temps d'une ville de 15 mille habitants
un livre